El Secretario de Estado Rex Tillerson, el
jefe de la diplomacia de los Estados Unidos
acaba de regresar de su primera gira por América
Latina.
No ha sido el primer viaje oficial de un alto
cargo de la Administración Trump a la región
Hace unos meses, en el verano de 2017, el
mismísimo Vicepresidente, Mike Pence, tuvo
su propia expedición Latinoamérica, visitando
Panamá, Colombia, Argentina y Chile.
Creo que todos lo sabemos, la relación entre
Estados Unidos y Latinoamérica es muy, pero
que muy especial…[lo que no quiere decir
buena]
Y no lo digo solo porque en Estados Unidos
viven cerca de 60 millones de hispanos, también
por los precedentes históricos, los lazos
comerciales y muchas cuestiones de seguridad.
Sin ir más lejos, el 25%, 1 de 4 dólares
del comercio de Estados Unidos tiene como
destino esta región.
Sin embargo, amigos, lo cierto es que la sensación
que han dejado las giras del Vicepresidente
y el Secretario de Estado es que a ojos de
esta Administración, a ojos a la Administración
Trump, Latinoamérica es más una molestia
que una oportunidad…
y, ojo, porque decir esto con todo lo que ha dicho
Trump desde que anunció que se presentaría
a las elecciones creo que es quedarse muy,
pero que muy corto.
Mirad, si tuviéramos que describir la relación
entre Estados Unidos y Latinoamérica hoy,
podríamos decir que Estados Unidos es como
ese amigo que te está todo el día pidiendo
y exigiendo cosas pero que a la hora de la
verdad no está dispuesto a hacer absolutamente
nada por ti.
Sí, podríamos decir que Estados Unidos se está convirtiendo en ese amigo egocéntrico.
Una buena prueba de ello fue la surrealista
gira de Mike Pence, una gira sin prácticamente
objetivos en la que el VicePresidente estaba
más preocupado en tratar de impedir las insignificantes
relaciones comerciales entre Chile y Corea
del Norte;
o de conseguir que los argentinos compraran
la carne de cerdo de su estado, Indiana, que
de las mismísimas relaciones entre Estados
Unidos y Latinoamérica ¡De locos!
Pero… ¿Sabéis qué?
La China de Xi Jinping está al acecho.
Pues bien, en este vídeo vamos a ver qué
quiere, qué espera Donald Trump de América
Latina y también que ocurre con China.
Pero antes, echemos un vistazo a la historia.
AMÉRICA PARA LOS NORTEAMERICANOS.
EN 1823, el por aquel entonces Presidente
de Estados Unidos, James Monroe, puso en marcha
la que más tarde se conocería como Doctrina
Monroe:
“América para los Americanos”, aunque
con el paso del tiempo casi que ha quedado
más como “América para los Norteamericanos”.
Veréis, esta doctrina, esta política, consistió
en defender que los estados europeos no tenían
derecho a intervenir en los asuntos americanos
ni en los países que por aquel entonces se
estaban independizando… de España.
Un momento… ¿Estados Unidos protegiendo
a Latinoamérica defendiendo la no intervención?
Suena bien ¿Verdad?
Pues… esperad un momento, porque lo cierto
es que esta doctrina, esta política, condujo
a Washington a hacer prácticamente de todo
en América Latina, una región que desde
entonces es conocida como el patio trasero
de Estados Unidos.
Sí, tal como lo escucháis.
Quienes nos estáis viendo desde allí estoy
seguro que lo sabeis bien.
Desde que James Monroe puso en marcha esta
forma de ver las cosas,
Estados Unidos ha puesto gobiernos, ha derribado
gobiernos;
Ha financiado guerrillas, ha financiado ejércitos,
Ha comprado políticos, ha pactado con narcotraficantes,
ha legitimado golpes de estado…
y así una larga pero que muy larga lista
de acciones dirigidas, según la época, bien
a luchar contra el comunismo, bien a defender
los intereses de las grandes multinacionales
norteamericanas.
Sí, ojo, vamos a ver, también se han hecho
cosas buenas, sobre todo en los últimos años,
cuando las relaciones más… cómo decirlo, opacas,
dieron paso a una estrategia por parte de
Washington más enfocadas a la resolución
de conflictos internos,
(“Este fue el caso, por ejemplo, del Plan
Colombia impulsado por Bill Clinton, o de
la estrategia de impulso al comercio de George
Bush que le llevó a firmar ni más ni menos
que 10 nuevos tratados de libre comercio con
países latinoamericanos e incluso a proponer
que toda América se convirtiese en un gran
área de libre comercio.”)
Pero aun así, las relaciones entre América
Latina y Estados Unidos siempre han sido muy
peculiares…
Veréis, en base a la doctrina Monroe, Washington
siempre se ha sentido una especie de “tutor legal”
capaz de decidir qué estaba bien,
que estaba mal, que era recomendable o que
no era recomendable.
Pero.. todo tutor tiene que tener claro que
los intereses del representado tienen que
estar por encima de los suyos propios… y
este no ha sido, para nada, el caso.
Bien, hace un año que Donald Trump está
en La Casa Blanca…. así que ahora sí veamos
qué quiere el presidente de Estados Unidos
de Latinoamérica, ¿Qué espera él?
¿Qué podemos esperar nosotros?
Veámoslo.
¿QUÉ QUIERE DONALDTRUMP?
Creo que no es una sorpresa para nadie, Donald
Trump no es el mayor fan de Latinoamérica.
Su preocupación por la región es muy pero
que muy pequeña a excepción de eso sí de
Cuba, Venezuela y sobre todo, México.
(Y ojo, porque Trump muestra tan poco interés
por Latinoamérica que un año después de
ser presidente, aún no ha nombrado a nadie
para el cargo de Secretario de Estado Adjunto
para Asuntos Hemisféricos, que viene a ser
el responsable específico de la diplomacia
con América Latina.
Algo absolutamente insólito.)
Eso sí, que tenga poco interés en las relaciones
con la región no ha impedido que la haya
convertido en el muñeco del Pim Pam Pum.
Ni tampoco quiere decir que no espere nada.
Me explico.
El primer año de Trump ha estado marcado
por los insultos a México, por su empeño
con el muro y ha llegado incluso a amenazar
a Colombia, como luego veremos.
Y no solo eso, amigos, ¿Queréis algunos
ejemplos más?
Pues… atentos:
(Durante 2017, Trump también dió marcha
atrás, lo vimos aquí en Visual Politik,
al acercamiento de Obama con Cuba, sin plantear,
eso sí, realmente ninguna alternativa;
También recobrando las peores costumbres
de la diplomacia norteamericana en América
Latina ha legitimado y apoyado la “sospechosa”
reelección de Juan Orlando Hernández en
Honduras.)
Y la última, ya en 2018, su gobierno ha decidido
suspender el llamado “Estatus de Protección
Temporal” para los inmigrantes de Nicaragua,
Honduras, Haití y sobre todo, El Salvador.
Y ojo porque con esta decisión 200.000 inmigrantes
de El Salvador ¡200.000!
tendrán que abandonar Estados Unidos o pasar
a una situación de ilegalidad.
(“Teníamos la esperanza de que si trabajábamos
duro, pagábamos impuestos y no nos metíamos
en problemas, nos permitirían quedarnos”.
Verónica Lagunas, salvadoreña de 39 años
y madre de dos hijos nacidos en Estados Unidos.)
E insisto, estos son solo algunas ejemplos,
la lista es larga.
Tal vez, amigos, esto es lo que explica que
el nivel de popularidad de Trump en la región
sea tan bajo…. qué digo bajo, está por
los suelos.
(En 2017 Gallup preguntó a los ciudadanos
de América Latina sobre que opinión tenían
del Presidente Trump.
Pues bien, tan solo el 16%, una de cada 6
personas, dijo tener una opinión positiva.)
Pero amigos, hay una pregunta importante que
tenemos que hacernos
¿Tanto agravio quiere decir que Trump pasa
de Latinoamérica y no busca, no quiere nada de ella?
Para nada, su gobierno está exigiendo varias
cosas a los países de la región pero sobre
todo 3 principales:
Primero, un apoyo incondicional a su política
exterior, incluida su política con Venezuela.
Segundo, que renuncien o pongan freno a la
influencia de China.
Y tercero, que asuman las culpas de todo,
ya sea pagando el muro o asumiendo más responsabilidades
en la lucha contra el narcotráfico.
Sí, salvo la cuestión de China el resto
de exigencias pueden llegar a ser razonables,
pero ¿Sabéis cuál es el verdadero problema?
Que la Administración de Trump no pone sobre
la mesa alternativas, no parece dispuesta
a dar nada a cambio y todo lo hace bajo el
planteamiento de estas conmigo… o contra mi.
Pero, vale, puede que estéis pensando.
Vamos a ver, Alberto… seguro, seguro que
también ha puesto sobre la mesa cosas positivas…
¿Verdad?
Pues… creo que para contestar a esta pregunta
lo mejor es ver cómo Trump está tratando
a los mejores aliados de Estados Unidos en
la región.
LOS AMIGOS
Creo que podemos decir, sin temor a equivocarnos,
que Colombia, Honduras y México han sido
tradicionalmente los mejores aliados de Estados
Unidos en la región.
Pues… ¿Sabéis que?
Con Trump en La Casa Blanca eso no está sirviendo
de mucho.
Fijaos en estas declaraciones que Trump hizo
mientras Rex Tillerson estaba de gira tratando
de fortalecer los lazos con Latinoamérica.
("Estos países no son nuestros amigos.
Saben, pensamos que son nuestros amigos y
les mandamos ayudas masivas.
Y ahora no voy a citar sus nombres (...), les
mandamos ayudas masivas y están llenando
nuestro país de drogas y se están riendo
de nosotros".
Donald Trump.)
Trump no da nombres, pero no hay duda de que
se estaba refiriendo a México, Colombia,
Honduras y P erú.
Sobre México qué decir… el muro, la renegociación
del NAFTA… los ataques han sido continuos
desde que Trump anunció su candidatura.
[No me extraña que los mexicanos le deis
a Trump una valoración media de 1,6 puntos
sobre 10]
Fijémonos también en Colombia, el país
que mejor relación ha tenido históricamente
con Estados Unidos.
(Colombia fue el único país latinoamericano
que envió tropas a la Guerra de Corea, un
país que le dio su apoyo a Estados Unidos
en 2003 para la invasión de Irak y un país
cuyas políticas siempre, siempre han estado
alineadas con los intereses de Washington
ya fuese en su política hacia Cuba, hacia
China o hacia Palestina.)
Pues ni siquiera eso ha impedido que Trump
amenazase a este país con considerarlo como
no cooperante con el cumplimiento de los compromisos
internacionales y la lucha contra el narcotráfico.
Algo que tendría serias consecuencias económicas
y políticas.
(“No solo es tratar de forma grosera a un
aliado cercano que está intentando resolver
el problema, es también un grave error.
Envía un mensaje tóxico al resto de la región:
aún si hacen lo que pide EE.UU., si están
en desacuerdo con parte de nuestra estrategia,
reaccionaremos contra ustedes".
Adam Isacson, Coordinador de la Oficina de
Washington para Asuntos Latinoamericanos.)
Sí, es verdad, que la producción de coca
ha repuntado mucho en Colombia y que el país
no ha sido capaz de vencer al narcotráfico..
pero ¿amenazar de esa forma al país que
más ha sufrido la guerra contra los narcos
sin proponer nada diferente?
(“Hemos perdido a nuestros mejores líderes,
nuestros mejores periodistas, nuestros mejores
jueces, nuestros mejores policías en esta
guerra contra el narcotráfico”.
Juan Manuel Santos.)
Y respecto a Honduras, el otro gran aliado…
que os voy a decir, os lo hemos contado aquí,
en VisualPolitik, que ha ocurrido con el más
que probable golpe de estado de
Juan Orlando Hernández.
E incluso en Argentina… un país que está
virando y que, no sé, sería lógico que
Washington le echara un cable… pues ni con
esas.
Trump exige mucho a Latinoamérica pero no
está dispuesto a dar mucho a cambio, ni siquiera
a los mejores amigos de Estados Unidos en
esta región.
Y China lo sabe.
CHINA AL ACECHO
China, la influencia en la región está empezando
a ser una gran obsesión para Estados Unidos.
El propio Rex Tillerson, ha sacado a pasear
la Doctrina Monroe para decir que Estados Unidos
tiene el derecho a bloquear la interferencia
de otra potencia en america.
[Y me pregunto yo, ¿quien le ha dado a Estados
Unidos ese derecho?]
(“América Latina no necesita nuevas potencias
imperiales que sólo buscan beneficiar a su
propio pueblo" Rex Tillerson en la Universidad
de Texas.)
Tiene gracia que diga estas cosas precisamente
el Secretario de Estado de Estados Unidos;
y sobre todo el Secretario de Estado de una Administración como la de Trump.
Vamos a ver me explico, los países latinoamericanos
tienen todo el derecho del mundo a buscar
alianzas, mercados e inversiones.
Y sí estas son chinas…
(Tal vez, lo que Tillerson debería preguntarse
es como es posible que Xi Jiping haya visitado
más veces la región en los últimos 5 años,
que el presidente de Estados Unidos,
teniendo en cuenta tanto a Barack Obama como a Donald Trump.
O qué China esté dispuesta a impulsar acuerdos
comerciales e inversiones mientras que Trump
está empeñado en castigar a México, levantar
muros o restringir el comercio. Por ejemplo,
tumbando el TPP, el mayor acuerdo comercial
de la historia en el que participan entre
otros países México, Perú y Chile.)
Fijaos, en la última reunión de la Comunidad
de Estados de América Latina y el Caribe,
China anunció 250 mil millones de dólares
en inversión en la región durante la próxima
década.
Si Estados Unidos quiere mantener su peso,
su influencia y seguir determinando la agenda
política, tal vez debería de tener una estrategia
política que realmente se preocupara de los
intereses de Latinoamérica.
Pero ahora turno para ti, del 1 al 5 ¿Cómo
valoras la influencia de Estados Unidos en
Latinoamérica?
Déjanos tu opinión en los comentarios y
también en esta encuesta.
Si te ha resultado interesante el vídeo dale
a like y no olvides suscribirte a VisualPolitik.
Un saludo y hasta la próxima.